so one of the most common debates you'll
read about online in books videos
newspapers all over the places our
entrepreneurs born or they made and
whose write this thing gets heated you
sit at you know tables and oh there's
everybody's born as an entrepreneur Elon
Musk was born with SpaceX PayPal and
Tesla and then you know the base I've no
that's not you know John Doe even though
he doesn't know what he's thinking about
he can one day become an entrepreneur
hopeful wishful they can become one you
can do it there's no way you're only a
la musk or you're not who's right ok so
I think the first thing we need to do I
was having dinner this past week
Thanksgiving have friends and family
over and one of the topics that came up
was love somebody brought up a question
about hey Pat what does it take to run a
nonprofit organization where you're not
paying anybody salaries for instance how
do you get a volunteer army to be
excited about so one of the most
important thing is love I said well
here's a question let's define love and
I asked everybody one by one by one to
give their definition of love watch what
happens there is 12 people around the
table do you know how many different
definitions we got we got eight
different definitions of what love is
everyone said something different
unconditional sacrifice quality of time
everybody says something different I
watch what the problem is here this is
one of the reason why relationships
sometimes don't work out my meaning of
love is different than your meaning of
love then we clash so you don't love me
anymore you don't love me anymore I
don't love like you do you don't love
like I do
you don't love me the way I want to be
loved so today we're going to start off
by first defining what it means to
become an entrepreneur you see there are
a lot of different definitions but I
wanted to go to top two sources
dictionaries Oxford and Cambridge let's
see how they define what it is to become
an entrepreneur Cambridge a person who
attempts to make a profit by starting a
company or by operating alone in the
business world especially when it
involves taking risks this is Cambridge
now let's look at Oxford a person who
sets up a business or businesses taking
on financial risks in the hope of profit
this is what they're saying the word
profit is used the word risk is used on
both X definitions right
so okay since we know it has to do with
starting a business having a risk and
possibly the desires to go out and
create a profit phenomenal but how many
different things do we hear about what
it is to become an entrepreneur you'll
hear a lot of people say entrepreneurs
are creative they're problem solvers
they're visionaries they want to find
things to do it better they're leaders
they're great salespeople they're
energetic they're charismatic they're
just so their eyes goes all of it is
bouncing all over the place every time
you talk about anything they can stay on
one thing they get bored quickly all the
hypomanic they're men all these things
we hear about on what it is to become an
entrepreneur they're artists you know
they're they're calm during pressure
they're resourceful okay we hear all
these things does that mean they're born
or does that mean they're made so let's
go first why they believe entrepreneurs
are born so the argument on
entrepreneurs people who think
entrepreneurs are born is typically made
by two different arguments to different
people this is mindful when I study this
I see two different people that make the
argument about being born one is those
who tried it and miserably failed they
lost everything
so it's an argument to say I failed and
because of that entrepreneurs are born
and the other one is they were somebody
who became successful and they fully
believe they're smarter they're stronger
they're faster they're better than
everybody else in the way they think so
in a way those who become successful
they think they're better than other
people in one way or another it's almost
becomes an elite status where there is a
elitist feeling to say I think better
than you therefore I was going to become
an entrepreneur you were not here's
another thing with entrepreneurship
those who think they were born there's
another mindset that says things like
you know where they forget sometimes
when you become wealthy and all of a
sudden you go from having no money to
all of us saying you're worth 100
million dollars two hundred million
dollars a billion dollars what happens
is everybody starts telling you how
amazing you are it's a very very very
dangerous thing by the way most people
don't know what it is to have people
tell you this it's just like when people
say you know I cannot believe such and
such you know slept around and he did
this this this this this for example
whatever argument it is do you know what
it is to be the hottest guy in the world
where every magazine tells you the most
handsome guy in the world don't you
think it would mess with your head a
little bit think about if you're a girl
and every magazine tells you the most
drop-dead gorgeous girl in the world how
would you walk I want you to think about
it right now millions of people around
the world tell you're amazing how do you
watch you walk like this a little bit do
you kind of play hard-to-get do you have
an attitude a little bit what would
happen to you so sometimes when these
entrepreneurs become very wealthy
powerful big houses cars let's just say
a lot of influence on social media all
these comments on the bottom you're so
amazing you're so amazing you're so
amazing you're so amazing
I am so amazing therefore I am better
than you
so that thought becomes entrepreneurs
have to be born because I am so special
and I'm born another thing that can
happen sometimes is it could be a kid
that grew up with a father who was an
entrepreneur so his father was an
entrepreneur his father could have ran a
restaurant his father could have ran a
small business his father could've ran
something small where his father was the
one that founded the business this kid
started working under his father he
helped grow his father's business so he
had an incredible family mom and dad
believed in him everything was great and
that gave him this opportunity to become
successful and he in his mind this is
what he believes in his mind the only
world he's living in is his own world
he believes for you to become successful
guess what guess what you have to have a
very loving family that they tell you
they love you they're so special they're
so amazing they hug you they love you
all this other stuff and you have to
have a father who was an entrepreneur
she can go out and watch them and
because you have an edge on everybody
else
therefore entrepreneurs are born is that
a good argument maybe he's right maybe
she's right now let's look at the other
argument where the argument is you know
I believe anybody can do it anybody can
be an entrepreneur this argument can be
anyone can become an entrepreneur anyone
can become an entrepreneur you know the
you know it's good for the economy to
believe that anybody can become an
entrepreneur great social media
technology has made the platform bigger
for anybody to become an entrepreneur
because it's so much easier today to
start a business online whether you're
an introvert or an extrovert you don't
have to have a personality of a sales
person you can be
a Mark Zuckerberg introvert that doesn't
want all the limelight and you design a
website and you work 60 billion you're
an introvert before you have to be a
salesperson output you don't even have
to talk to people nowadays to make a
product you can make it as it you know
so anybody can become an entrepreneur
another one is there are more examples
of success today any time there are more
examples of success and a certain
platform highlight some all like today
if you go on YouTube and type an
entrepreneur there are so many videos
today about entrepreneurship if you go
on google and type in entrepreneur
billions of searches comes out about
entrepreneur what does that tell you
it is more thought about today than it
was years ago so what does that mean
when they make the argument that anybody
can become an author I want to think
about this so there used to be a time
back in the days where an attractive
woman was somebody that was a bigger
woman so if you go back and study
history of women and how men were
attracted to a woman years ago it was
the bigger the woman the more attractive
men were to them now why is that why do
you think that is because somebody of
stature liked bigger woman and everybody
said if a powerful person likes bigger
woman then I need to like bigger woman
then it changed then the media started
telling us that the most attractive
woman in the world are what extremely
skinny there's six one and there are 75
pounds if you know what I'm talking like
they're so skinny see all the bones so
I'm just gonna my gosh this is so
beautiful why because Calvin Klein puts
these magazines out everybody's like
this like Zoolander do you know what I'm
talking about the Zoolander thing that
you see every bone they have because oh
she's so sexy
and then we went away from that face oh
you know what it is today what's today
today you have a girl that's got 60
million followers on Twitter with
stacked back here so guess what guess
what's sexy today
voluptuous thick curved a curvy that's
sexy today I want to have a girl that
looks like Kim Kardashian because that's
what's sexy today
right okay Pat what are you going with
this very simple people started
bodybuilding because of Steve Reeves he
was you know I think it Reeves was the
first one it was a first up it was a
first mist rolling people he played him
movie I think he was the first Hercules
yes I think we was Steve Reese he put
his arms out boom here at these 19 inch
20 inch guns everybody wanted to be a
bodybuilder then Arnold became a
bodybuilder then Arnold went into movies
and everybody wanted have an amazing
body so our dough started an epidemic
I've wanted to become what bodybuilders
it's what he did today today
Steve Jobs Zuckerberg Bezos Wozniak
Michael Dell all these guys Elon Musk
they are so big today that everybody
wants to become an entrepreneur which
means what here's what it means the
school of thought that thinks anybody
can do it because there are more
examples of people winning people start
to believe there are so many becoming
entrepreneurs I can also be coming on to
a belief level has become so high in the
market for competitiveness has become so
high so everybody wants to become an
entrepreneur does that mean they're
right I don't know if that means they're
right I can't tell you they're right or
they're not right so there is a trend
today about reproduction maybe it wasn't
the case 30 years ago 40 years ago
because pension plans were around so
much and everybody wanted to go out
there land a great job at a big for and
if I work here for 30 years they're
gonna give me a pension plan I've said I
don't need to start a business I don't
need to start a business and then phone
10 years ago
pension plans are being canceled United
Airlines defaults on a big pension plan
oh we can't do it anymore
134 thousand pension plans go to 20,000
pension plans in America then all these
people that were working for company for
30 years saying why am i working you for
30 years I don't have equity I don't
have stocks I don't have profits and I'm
not getting pension what am i doing is
maybe I ought to consider what
entrepreneurship so the school of
thought is people are realizing I need
to become an entrepreneur so they're
making a decision to go become an
entrepreneur so let's stay on that
argument a little bit have some fun with
it let's get silly a little bit it's
okay we'll have some fun here but how
this won't make sense to you
when people say to me Pat entrepreneurs
are born here's what I say to them I
said okay
you see entrepreneurs are born no
problem a guy named Archie Manning has
three kids okay he used to be a
quarterback a football player he was a
quarterback he has three kids his oldest
son his name is Peyton Manning
guess what he ends up doing he becomes a
quarterback was he born to become a
quarterback or is it accidental because
man maybe he was destined to become a
court about anyone's two Super Bowl
championships Archie second kid his name
is Eli
guess what he became he became a
quarterback and guess what he did he
went to Super Bowl championship now what
a father he got lucky right and a third
son what does he become he becomes a
court of oh my gosh
accidental no there's a reason why they
became quarterbacks they had their
father who is the most ridiculous
teacher to teach them to become a
quarterback so they started mixing you
know father 1 7 and 8 and they're
they're Manning family or quarterbacks
so Kennedy was somebody born to become a
politician know the father Joseph
Kennedy had an aspiration of given birth
he wanted to go into politics so his
kids ended up becoming into politics his
he thought Joseph was gonna be the one
cuz he was a super soldier he went into
the military one her to fight so hard
that he ended up killing himself on war
so Joseph the father who named his first
son Joe who he was planning on having
Joe become a president Joe doesn't
become a president he's devastated and
the kid the underdog nobody believed
that was going to become the president
John F Kennedy he becomes a president he
had back problems health problems he
becomes a president and one of the most
loved President then that entire
families and politics were those kids
born to go into politics I don't think
so I don't think so what happened to
that family some happened there so in
basketball I'll give you another example
let's talk about sports if I'm 14 years
old six eight who do you think's going
to come and talk to me the music teacher
no I want you to think about I'm six
eight in school
so visualize me I'm going through a
locker room I take these long steps you
know how six the way I walk I'm taking
these long steps and then all of us are
who spots me basketball coach who's that
kid
oh he just moved here from New Jersey oh
my gosh how old is he 14 no he looks
like he's 35
no no he's 14 years old I want to talk
to bring him afterwards hey kid what's
your name John you ever play basketball
before John no do you like basketball
it's okay uh well we're gonna teach you
how to play basketball kid okay
you want to play for the team and have
girls like you and cheerleaders aren't
you I'll play great come on we're going
to show you they give them a ball shoot
the basketball
this kid cannot shoot a basketball shoot
a basketball is no cool what he's doing
then they work on him
then they put somebody to work on his
footwork practice with them teach him
defense next thing you know they have a
center that 6 8 14 years old two years
later he's 71 two years later he's
playing for a college team for one year
two years that he's gets a hundred
million dollar contract to play for some
team there he is the next guy he's six
eight was he born to become an
entrepreneur a basketball player nearly
six eight you your target here's another
one let's just say I'm a kid and you
know I go to tryout
ok or I'm doing whatever I'm doing and
all of a sudden all the friends are
doing a race you know how we're one
we're kids we want to compete about
anything so hey who can do a handstand
so we do a handstand I'm terrible at
handstand hypothetically
hey who can't throw a ball someone
throws oh my gosh that guy's got a
strong arm you remember these things who
punches the hardest so didn't punch my
shoulder my your one hurt
punch me these are stupid things we do
as kids punch my shoulder punch I don't
pile up man this kid hits hard it was
always that one kid that would hit a man
that stinks
ok let's you can jump the longest and
then this one kid jumps he can jump
didn't he can't jump then one guy comes
jumps
oh my gosh this guy flew he's flying
this guy's a bird I know this is insane
what happened here
this guy could from he he definitely
great-grandpa was a bird or something
there was an eagle in that family
lineage then out of a some people find
that he's got a reputation
hey there's jump and Johnny who finds
out about jumping Johnny
the track and field coach or the
volleyball coach hey bring this jumping
Johnny guy
hey John Johnny show us how much you
jump ok boom holy moly 40 inches 40
inches means what track volleyball
basketball was he born to go into track
oh come on man
that guy's got a god-given ability right
what if I have a quick first step what
if I come very quick with my hands I'm
very quick there's this boxing this is
this is good stuff what if I born and
raised in the streets ghetto you got
like a guy like in bad areas and you got
to batter your boney you don't have a
choice some people are born in that area
what do you think boxers come from who's
one of the top middleweight boxers what
was his name
Tyson is heavyweight Evander Holyfield
came from light heavyweight and he
became eventually champion not
mayweather who was the other guy that he
went to prison he was in prison for five
years and then he came out he was he was
he had like Naju not Durant no this is
an african-american he's phenomenal
but phenomenal what's his name he had a
beard what's his name not Roy Jones it
was another guy and it was look him up
look him up right now while I'm talking
and pull him up in your phone so this
guy grew up in the streets and he had to
fight his way to the top he had to fight
his way to the top so all of a sudden
everybody's fighting when this guy's
fighting back finding my silence and
everybody knows how to box and this guy
goes to prison in prison he has to
protect himself he has to protect
himself so all of a sudden he was middle
middleweight and then he comes out and
he starts competing any wizard Chet he
fights till 48 years old cleans up his
act becomes a boxer boxer how did he
become a boxer here's another one
Bernard Hopkins Bernard Hopkins okay so
here's another one here's another one I
want you to think about what it takes to
be a jockey jockey horse jockey you know
what it is when they're riding on the
horse can I be a horse jockey what if I
want to become a horse jockey so the
argument here anyone can become an
entrepreneur can I become a horse jockey
what do you think can I um I'm 6 5 to 40
you know what would happen to that poor
horse that horse would be like I can't
do this anymore I give up
you know what's the ideal high for horse
jockey for eight for ten to five six you
know what the weight is 108 to 118 can
you imagine so if you weigh 149 you
can't be a jockey did you do you can't
play at that level right can you imagine
Shaq he's 72 400 pounds Kenny of you
jockey you
he used a horse the horse gets on his
back so try to visualize this right so
there are very good arguments on the
born side and are very good arguments on
the build side so who is right which
argument is right because there are
things that we got it and I know it
sounds a little silly to you when I'm
talking about this so let's ask the
following question let's ask the
following question on why do people
become entrepreneurs because this is a
very important question for us to ask
why do people become entrepreneurs okay
why do people become entrepreneurs
so one similar to the story I told you
about with Manning how you know his
three boys become quarterbacks and not
just football specific quarterbacks and
he was a quarterback his to over someone
to championship that's insane so why
does somebody become an entrepreneur
because his family or her family were
filled with entrepreneurs Donald Trump
goes into real estate his father was in
real estate for a trompe you know you
see a lot of these you know Kennedy's
politics politics you see a lot of this
lineage football football so one of the
reasons why people become an
entrepreneur is because their family was
an entrepreneur so someone may say I
think you have to be born well you were
born in a family with a father that was
an entrepreneur so you think everybody
has to have a father that's an
entrepreneur to become an entrepreneur
my father wasn't an entrepreneur and
quite frankly I was born in a
middle-eastern family where first time I
dad told me he loves me I was 21 years
old and you know how he did it here's
how we did it I called my dad one day
and it's not that he doesn't he's a very
loving the most loving man I know he
just doesn't say it so one day I pull my
dad said dad guess what what's that I
said I want to hear you tell me you love
me I just got out of the military scam
okay could relax you become too
Americanized
we're Middle Eastern I'm a Syrian I
don't have to tell you I love you I said
dad I wanna hear you tell me how we need
to hear your daughter on your son want
to hear you say you love you love us
this is what is wrong with you have you
lost it have you been to Americanize
after this military thing I said look
you just need to start saying it cuz
people need to know our grandkids are
gonna want to hear you say I love you so
I go to work the next day at Bally's I
get a call my dad never calls me at work
he calls me I'll work and I say hey pop
what's going on hey how you doing I'm
doing good pop hey I just want to tell
you what step up I love you and he hangs
up on me I said that's how he first time
he told me he loves me can you imagine
that my mother my dad they never grew up
saying you're gonna be so amazing you're
so special
some guys have that I don't have that in
most of the world does it that doesn't
mean you need to have that perfect
situation to become an entrepreneur but
that is his argument it doesn't have to
be your argument okay so number one
family I know a guy pastor Dudley whose
entire family's filled with pastors so
many they're all pastors brothers
pastors uncles pastors fathers pastor
grandpa
everyone's a pastor were they born to
become a pet and their incredible
pastors were they born to become a
pastor you know
family they're fun why they become an
entrepreneur why they become a pastor
why did you become a footballer I want
to become a politician family number two
someone they looked up to someone they
looked up to someone becomes an
entrepreneur because an uncle a friend
or relative a next-door neighbor or
whatever it is someone they said I want
to be like him they read a magazine I
want to be like Rockefeller I want to be
like this movie star I watch this movie
and he was a financial adviser I want to
be the next you know the legal version
of Gordon Gekko I want to be bud Fox and
land those big cells I want to be the
next they saw somebody who's a
successful entrepreneur they want to be
like number three it's the only way out
it's the only way out what do I mean by
the only way out well you know some if
you're if you're born in the bad side is
school if you listen to any of Tupac's
you know a songs and you actually listen
and you read it forget about listening
to you just read it Brenda's got a baby
that script if you listen to that song
Brenda's got a baby
an average person reading that song is
going to say I can't even listen to it
so painful what Brenda's got a baby at
12 years old he's telling a real story
of what happens in that community with a
12 you're getting pregnant that's not a
myth that happens to you maybe never in
a million years but that happens so what
is the expression with entrepreneurship
desperation can be meant the only way
for me to be out is to start a business
I go to Mexico and every time I go to
Mexico here you want to buy a gun hey
tienes chiclet you want to buy a gun do
one about gum cheek legit legit legit
later you want to buy gum do you want
why are those six year old selling gum
desperation it's their only way out it's
their only way out they have to make
money their parents even said they got
three kids they're all selling gum Artic
I'm I wrote actually see these kids are
grown up learning about hard work at
five six seven eight years of their
learning persuasion kid comes up to me
senior seen you and they give you smile
they're learning about charm persistency
never given up hey Chi clan chitlin and
you look at the skin you look how can I
say no to you man here's a dollar that
come costs five cents here's a dollar
that's a ten thousand percent markup
here's a dollar man go ahead you're good
hey gracias and we walk away okay
desperation entrepreneurship there's a
level of desperation number three a
number four a dream the dispersed ones
got a dream I have a dream
what's your dream I want to live in a
better
my family lived in a dream I saw my
parents going through a divorce I don't
want to live my life a dream we grew up
broke first time I ever went first time
I ever went and had dinner at a nice
restaurant my mother took us to Sizzlers
restaurant I thought everybody in the
room was millionaires millionaires
sizzler is nothing I go into sizzler the
first time I had any kind of a nice
restaurant is that Sizzlers restaurant
18 years old my mother did her best she
didn't have the money we go to this
restaurant scissors I'm sitting at
little Akane even look how now you have
an 18 year old kid I'm looking at
everybody my sister Paulette look
everybody here's rich man we're having
dinner with rich people what is Sizzlers
it was like it was a dream first time I
had a lobster it's in the army we went
and we had Lobster at Red Lobster 24
dollars
oh my gosh we spent twenty four dollars
on food for one meal this is I've never
done that so I didn't grow up with a
family with a lot of money to me that
was a big deal so there's a certain
level of dream what if we can't afford
what if I can take money what if I can
feed my parents what if they don't have
to ever worry about money what if I
could my parents sacrifice they came to
America I don't want my debt to ever pay
for I want to take my dad and travel all
over the world my dad had 13 heart
attacks six angiogram six angio plastics
three stents in his heart that I just
want to show you the world man I just
want you to meet your kids grandkids one
day I want to have my kids be able to
say they had a relation with a grandpa
because I never had a chance to meet my
grandpa that's a dream that gets me
mocking cry right now thinking about it
maybe there's a dream maybe there's a
dream you don't have to be born you
could be built and it's a dream that
motivates somebody become an
entrepreneur next one someone they
admired next one finding the right team
to run with I was at Texas A&M
University speaking to the
Entrepreneurship society is set up by
this kid named nan who's I believe from
Philippines or Thailand and they last
question a kid asked Pat if you could
tell us anything right now before
leaving what could be the one thing you
could tell us
I said look just look at Hollywood
Hollywood if you get into a clique of
four actors that do very well to get in
movies you'll keep doing movies with
them just look at look at groups of
people that you'll see Wow they've done
five movies together it's not accidental
it's a team this is intentional
sometimes a kid accidentally his name is
Daniel
he finds a guy named mark and Mark
starts a website called the Facebook and
Mark needs money Daniel gets 18 grand
gives it to a mark they start this
company
Daniel today's worth a couple billion
dollars Daniel is considered a multi
billionaire entrepreneur how did he do
it was he born to become an entrepreneur
no it's friends it's group of people its
team of people that were part of
accidentally they become an entrepreneur
last one is environment you know which
has to do with finding writing but it's
kind of different environment if you're
on other entrepreneurs you're going to
become an entrepreneur if you're on
anybody else that plays football soccer
basketball music guitar you can it
you're gonna pick up some of that
generally there'll be influence on that
for you to be part of so the last one
last one before we wrap up so I do
believe and agree with both of them let
me give you complete different argument
I have here I do believe when people say
entrepreneurs are born they're right I
also do believe when people say
entrepreneurs are well-made they're also
right here's the kicker the question
isn't about are they born in May are
they made at what level what's their
capacity on how big of an entrepreneur
they can be so there are three levels
one is becoming the greatest so somebody
asks can I become like Elon Musk No very
simple no this kid his father family
they were all rocket scientists they
thought like that from he was a kid II
talk like that
this kid devoured books at ten nine
years old strange mind yet no you can't
be a la mosquée you don't have to be
unless he's the greatest can I be
Michael Jordan no Michael Jordan's hands
would go around the ball Michael Jordan
jumped 49 inches 48 inches Michael
Jordan was 67 with an older brother
named Adrian I believe who bullied him
playing basketball and was better than
him so kind of pushed him and his data
took a liking on his older brother so
Mike's like you know what that you
believe in him more than me
watch what I'm gonna do to you I'm boom
you had a chip on his shoulder you can't
be Mike because good Mike's got some
god-given abilities so you can't be the
greatest acting Johnny Depp can you
become Johnny Depp no way in the world
there's only one Johnny Depp give me a
role Johnny's play
you didn't allison wonderland chocolate
you know chocolate thing dinner Chuck
willy wonka Scissorhands which is insane
21 Jump Street when she was a regular
kid jack spirit do you realize like the
complicated role to Scott plays someone
says I want to be like Johnny Depp let
me simplify for you know very simple
there's only one of them in 7 billion
people around the world very difficult
to become a Johnny Depp but here's the
good news
can you become a pro yes just not the
greatest you can build a business and
make millions of dollars I'm telling you
you can make a buildup and make millions
of dollars you can go play the game of
basketball and b53 160 pounds and be
Muggsy Bogues playing basketball Monday
in the NBA you can go play the game of
football and be work done five seven one
five eight 170 what is he 580 170
running back Scott would get popped he
played for I don't know ten years he had
a pretty good career he's never gonna be
the greatest but he was a pro you can go
become an actor and be in movies are you
ever gonna be a Depp no but you can be a
prone enjoy it you can become an
entrepreneur make a half a million
you're a million dollars you're ten
million dollars here you just may not be
the greatest and who cares
you didn't choose you wanted to become
purpose was a different purpose on why
you chose to become an entrepreneur last
one is this last one is fun can I play
basketball
yes a mine you good at it no can I can I
learn to have some fun with basketball
yes can I be a decent actor and do
videos on you to them put it up and get
a few laughs yes of course can I go out
there and you know start a business and
for fun just say hey I like making these
little sandwiches because I like the way
I me know everyone likes it when I do my
barbecue I'm on a for fun start doing
these barbecues on weekends and see
what's going to happen and start passing
out flyers hey everybody you guys could
come when I used to make barbecue
everybody would show up so imagine if I
say hey 200 flyers pass them out this
Sunday I'm doing barbecue from 1:00 to
5:00 for fun let's do this chicken five
dollars a pop let's pass it up 50 people
show up in a community I sell 50
chickens for five dollars to 50 cost me
30 bucks to make it it cost me 30 bucks
to make it so that's for fine
you can do that as well so the next time
someone tells you our entrepreneurs born
or made
and if they go either way now you have
an argument on what to do with it
you got to redefine it ask them the
question what does it mean to become an
entrepreneur definition number two you
gotta ask them why they believe the way
they doing why they believe the way they
do the born or the build number three
why do people become entrepreneurs
number four what levels there's there's
the greatest you're right no you can't
become one you can become a pro and
anybody can have fun become an
entrepreneur making to 30 grand a month
part-time doing an online thing on eBay
that still is considered an entrepreneur
so with that being said whether you
agree disagree it doesn't matter
comment on the bottom with your thoughts
on if you believe entrepreneurs are born
or entrepreneurs are made I really want
to hear your thoughts and on top of that
first throw me the first subscribe
pillow this is exciting this pillow is
going to go into history books because
this pillow helped us get 200,000 subs
we will forever have a very special
emotional moment with this pillow if you
haven't subscribed to this channel I
posted a video four or five videos ago
that we were looking for a new pillow to
replace this this is going to go in the
pillow hall-of-fame and we're looking
for a new pillow for 2017 to use in
every single video that we'll do and
we're already getting a lot of people
sending us pillow here's a couple of
them send me that one okay this is one
of them that we just got this is from
Shahin Teti okay he's got a front and
backwards a black one it says subscribe
to value taming it's got the YouTube
logo on it and it's got the value tamer
logo on that's kind of cool here's
another one from michelle
she's got subscribe to value Tim and I'm
assuming Michelle this is how I would
use it from North Carolina subscribe to
value tamer which is kind of cool and
then this one is a simple one as well
value tame and subscribe with the
YouTube play button I like this one I
drop this what you call a fumble with a
pillow Paul
okay Paul dropped it as well anyways hey
if you want to participate and you want
to send a pillow you think you're
creative you know some people that can
make some custom pillows send it our way
the address is five thousand and one
Spring Valley Road Suite 1155 east
that's in Dallas Texas 75 244 send it
our way we
in a pic one before the end of the year
and we'll announce who the winner is if
we choose yours we'll give you love in
videos in emails on Facebook and it will
use it for the entire year of 2017
because we have a goal in 2017 of
getting two million subs so if you
haven't subscribed please do so any
thoughts about today's video comment on
the bottom thanks for watching everybody
take care bye bye
[Music]